Okay, let's take a look at the answer. If we use our genetic code, we see that
the first codon is TAC. So I'm going to look here, UAC, and
that's tyrosine, which we symbolize with Y. Then I'm let's take the next one,
CTG, CUG, which would be leucine or L. And then I am going to take the last one,
which is GGG. And look for GGG glycine, which is symbolized with the G. So
the answer is YLG. Now, what I hope none of you got tricked by is the fact that
I gave you the DNA sequence not the RNA sequence. This is a coding region of
DNA that will eventually be transcribed into the
mRNA, that at these same positions will say UAC
CUG GGG and so on, and we'll
have these three codons. But remember, when the coding region is copied into
the RNA intermediate, the mRNA, the thymines, or
Ts, are replaced by U's. And that's why our genetic code uses U's, is
because technically, the code that's being translated is not the DNA but the RNA
that's being turned into protein. The RNA is the
intermediate, and the DNA is where that RNA came from.
So, although I give you the original DNA sequence,
you should be able to figure out the protein by
simply replacing the thymines with uracils, or T's with
U's. And then reading the codons in that format, translating
it from the genetic code into the protein sequence
that you would get right here. So, in this case,
in the ABO gene, from position 793 to position 801
of the genetic code, the coding region of the gene, we
would get three amino acids from three codons, totaling nine
nucleotides, tyrosine or Y, L for leucene, and G for glycine.